Marty and I we went to a restaurant and
we um
we went there we're having a nice dinner
then all of a sudden towards dessert all
these guys start coming up these guys
would be coming up like auditioning for
him we were at this Italian restaurant
they heard that Morty was there and that
Marty uses real people in his movies and
basically they they were auditioning but
they did it by saying I knew a guy who
did this so these are like real life
Wise Guys but they wouldn't admit it
they all came up with stories as if they
were auditioning for him and when you
know they would all come in talk in
third person I knew a guy who did this
then the other one tops it I knew a guy
who did that I knew somebody who had the
whack this guy in a diner and and his
sister was there and their stories got
worse and worse and you know they were
talking about themselves so they were
just no I got some you think that's a
whacking hi little guy who had to whack
this guy in a diner and his mother was
and really they actually was like
competing with each other wow you don't
have to be in the FBI you just tell
people you're directing a movie and
you'll get all the information you need